that's my gavel as it being a little
after 10 I'm going to open the criminal
justice subcommittee work session on
House Bill 470 relative to fentel test
strips and other drug checking equipment
if I could have everyone please rise and
join me in the Pledge of
Allegiance okay thank you everyone I'm
going to take a slight recess as we uh
try to find our last remaining
representative so I will tempor arily
pause the meeting recess the
meeting
okay we will be reopening the
subcommittee work session on House Bill
47 z uh after a brief discussion with my
clerk we're going to decide that we will
go for a vote today so I'd like to have
if anyone has any information that
they'd like to speak about uh you
certainly
can
repr thatal we all knew it was coming
thank you very much Mr chair um and so I
I think that this is a wonderful bill I
think that it has been uh vetted fully
in the full committee uh we recently
passed the um legalization of strictly
testing and analy well strictly uh fenal
and xylazine test stps that's a
wonderful start what this does is this
really uh it fully fleshes out how we
can actually analyze or set up a
structure so that we can analyze uh and
know what's on our streets um and so
this goes a little bit further in the
way that it allows us to have more
accurate information um feny and
xylazine test strips um you know I use
the comparison to like a pregnancy test
but that's what it is you either are or
you aren't you know it either exists or
it doesn't but it doesn't tell you how
much it doesn't allow you to test for
multiple substances etc etc and so what
this does is allows us to have better
information which ultimately not only um
you know in the personal way that uh
fenel and xylazine test strips Empower
individuals to be able to make better
decisions about um you know whether or
not they want to use substances or not
um what this does is this empowers us as
a community to be able to better Target
and better better address um the things
that are creeping into our uh uh elicit
drug Supply and so I think that this
honestly can be nothing nothing but good
um from you know from all angles and so
I'm I'm very supportive of this bill if
you don't know that yet and uh thank you
for letting me
speak yeah we we also we have an
amendment that was proposed it was
discussed the last time around and I
think this was something that made it a
little more palatable across the board
it was kind of a a compromise thing so
we do have this amendment here but we
never voted on it it is uh amendment
number
515 um from February 14th 2023 when we
went to Executive session this was
available but we decided to retain it
instead um so you know I'm I'm happy to
uh pass that amendment I think that you
know they were they were good changes
that um that made it so that more people
on the committee and uh hopefully more
people in the broader house and in the
Senate um are more amendable to passing
this bill it's it's people are more
comfortable with it with with the
amendment so happy to to make a motion
to pass that make a motion to pass that
Amendment uh whatever you choose to to
do today chair uh thank you
representative uh represent Reed yes
thank you Mr chairman so the way I read
this um we pass the fentanyl test strips
um as a harm reduction tool makes
complete sense and of course we want to
minimize overdose deaths and we want to
provide people with the tools necessary
to determine if their drugs uh contain
fanal or siline however this bill is um
very very Broad and I have an issue with
um the drug par um drug paraphernalia
shall not include drug checking
equipment or processing preparing
packaging repackaging storing or
containing nominal amounts for the
purpose of drug checking and the amount
that is considered a nominal amount is
um not more than 10 milligrams so
what we're saying here is that people
can walk around with drug uh with uh uh
IL illegal substances less than 10
milligrams which is a lot and um we can
no longer um uh consider those um
previous stated um paraphernalia as
paraphernalia I do not see that as a
harm reduction tool I see that as an
enabling and very broad um I feel that
um this that number nine is too broad
and is more enabling than risk reduction
I am going to have to be an itl on this
um you know uh I just feel that again
this is not helping our our substance
misuse
um clients patients I see this as
enabling in no way is this going to help
them in their Journey um if anything
it's going to lead to their demise so um
I'm going to be an
itl thank you representative represent
n thank you um the the one thing that I
really wanted to clarify and I know it
was clarified when we were discussing it
before um but when we talk about 10
milligrams I think a lot of us think in
terms of like you know Tylenol or
something that we would get there's a
difference between if it's uh by weight
or by by volume and so when it's talking
about 10 milligrams it's not talking
about you know something that you know
we would get in the drug store and and
understand that that's that what they
say is it's um Lincoln on the head of a
penny so it's it's really it's a very
very small amount but um and so I I did
want to clarify that but um but the
other thing that I wanted to kind of
Broach here um so in one of the things
that we got one of the um letters in
support that we got um forget what
organization I think it was r street
it's it's anyway um so in one of the
letters that we got there was you know
kind of a list of references and I went
write down of course I read through all
the references good that's fun um you
know studies and and things there was
one um this is uh New Hampshire drug
monitoring initiative um through DHHS
and um or information analysis Center so
anyway so what this
does um New Hampshire drug monitoring
initiative is a holistic strategy to
provide awareness and combat drug
distribution and misuse in line with
this approach the DMI will obtain data
data from various sources to include but
not limited to public health law
enforcement and EMS and provide monthly
products for stakeholders as well as
substantial awareness and releases as
needed so that one that was that was
referenced in um in the bottom of that
letter because this was in you know
February or March or whatever it was um
this was up until October of 2022 so of
course I went and I looked it up and
found the more accurate or the more
updated one um not only you know I think
we're all pretty aware that overdose uh
deaths are are once again Rising um
substantially say it's back to 2016
levels um um 11.5% increase um in drug
overdoses and um that was from 20 uh 22
you know in comparison to 2021 and then
it's up 10% higher um this time around
in 2023 so um just kind of that as a
baseline but what what's interesting
that I found in this information really
caught my eye was that one of the things
that actually went down it says EMS
Naran Administration incidents and so um
you know I I guess you you'd really need
to dig into the correlation of of why
this is right but but one of the things
that really sticks out to me is that
we've made Narcan available um broadly
so that we are giving it out we are
educating people about it and that's
great that is a harm harm reduction tool
so we've we've intentionally gone out of
the way to put way more Naran um out for
personal use and taught people how to
use it and when they need to use it and
so it's happening more on an individual
level an individual saving uh another
person's life rather than having to call
emergency services and have them come
out that's a whole lot of economic uh
you know in Impact uh in that way but
also um if we if we kind of draw the
parallels here it's wonderful that the
EMS doesn't have to come out and that
you know but we will have less
information um as uh as a result because
EMS is not the EMS is the people who are
keeping the record so we're going to
have less information on how many
overdoses were reversed right so the
only reason I I call this out is because
I feel like there is um an analogy here
to the way that um you know it it's
wonderful that now people can test their
own Supply and things like that but we
are going to have less accurate numbers
because people are doing that in
individually rather than where it is
normally found out which would be you
know in a police interaction or
something like that right or you know
overdose or whatever it is the police
are able to understand what is on our
streets because of police interactions
if individuals or just in the same way
that people are able to get better
statistics on how many um overdoses were
reversed because they have an
interaction with the EMS um in E another
emergency service right um
so I I guess the point that I'm trying
to get to and you can tell me if I've
actually made this point properly or
effectively is that allowing for um
allowing for situations where people can
go um easily reducing barriers without
having the the criminal uh punishment
hanging over their head to be able to go
and get this information equips our
police better they will be more informed
in dealing with these elicit substances
being in our drug Supply
so go thank
you I'm just going to interject for us
thank you so much uh just for the record
of retired law enforcement State Police
uh I do want to have that harm reduction
and saving lives but I know firsthand
that there's subjects where they
overdose they use Naran they're good an
hour later the police get called back
they overdose they use Naran it's just a
vicious cycle of the adct knowing like
okay I can live I can live and I I can
live and again we don't want to see them
die but it seems like they're not taking
the steps to see and I know I'm not an
addict uh I can't be in an addict's mind
but it seems like they just keep the
Vicious Cycle over and over and over
again something maybe should be to them
to say I get to get my act straight I
don't know if that's a friend uh I know
you can speak a lot further on this but
I just know on my side EMS side it's the
Vicious Cycle of okay I'm going to take
as much as I can someone hopefully will
find me and then I get my shot I come
back that's my piece on that and I'll
have representative Reed speak okay I
think we're muddying the two things here
har or duct so the way I see it is um
you have your substance misuse um issues
so the people who are have the substance
um uh procure their substance I don't
see a lot of them testing however so say
you have a couple and some one of the uh
parts of the couple's very concerned
about their significant other they may
the thetically test to make sure their
partner's okay or in a group setting you
know let's so I am fully supportive of
the test strip component but what we're
missing here um is the fact that this is
still an elicit activity that we should
not be
encouraging being being arrested and
taken out of that environment for a
couple days is not such a bad thing I
that to be an addict is to have a demon
on your back 24 hours a day so here
we're just like okay you know here's all
the stuff you need to do to continue to
use and maybe if you don't die before
you have um hit rock po bottom you know
but in jail they may become addicts in
jail I understand that it's not a safe
Zone always but it is better than being
on the streets being enabled to
continually use um how many addicts
parents or loved ones beg for their
family members to be arrested so that
they at least know they're safe for a
little bit longer and here I I would as
from a nurse I would love to see
everybody test use clean needles do
their drugs in a healthy way but you
know that's not reality and the fact is
still it's an illicit activity that we
should not be encouraging and that's why
I have to still say itl I don't care
about statistics at this point I want in
reality we need to help them as best as
we can while still providing the um and
it's another thing the big drivers of
our crime rate is mental illness and
substance abuse so if we can eliminate
some of the substance abuse we would our
crime rates would would would improve as
well it's just we need to um look at
this realistically and not um through
Rose Colored Glasses that if
we pass this everything's going to be
great because you know it's
not representative
Newman I'll just make an observation
about what what we're going to do do
here today and we're not going to pass a
bill today we're not going to itl a bill
today we're not going to do that we're
going to make a recommendation to the
full
committee um I've heard two objections
made one objection is that that it's not
a good idea because of of what you said
about
um that it's not a good idea so it
should be it so that's the whole bill
that that's fine the if it were down to
the point about the 10 milligrams my my
opinion about something if if you had
something like that and that and that's
the sticking point then um you don't
just it the bill just you fix you don't
do a work around you don't kill it and
you you would would fix that little bit
so so I don't know but it sounds like
there's the bigger problem is the one
should we have it should we not have it
I don't know that we're not going to
resolve that today we will make a
recommendation
so that's all I have to say about that
and then there will be a bigger
discussion when whatever recommendation
comes out of what we do here goes to the
committee and that can happen today or
it can happen whenever you all decide to
to whether you're going to have
additional meetings or not you may just
come up with a recommendation today and
then we'll meet again in committee thank
you thank you representative for helping
us newbies figure out the process uh
representative n and then representative
selling I just I just wanted to clarify
really quickly that um I am in no way
looking through rosecolor glasses um I
was the one to receive the phone call
when my fiance at the time and father of
my two children was pulled over by the
state police and he was then in the
police barracks I used to call him a big
strong handsome man do you want to know
what he sounded like on that phone call
that was the beginning of his spiral
downward and it did not take long for
him to overdose in our bathroom on the
other side of a closed door with my
one-year-old knocking on the door saying
da da so I am not looking through
rose-colored glasses what I am looking
through is the eyes of a mother who has
raised two children through stigma
through all of everything that happens
through my own grief I had my youngest
three weeks later clutching pictures of
the family that I thought we were going
to be welcoming into I just I I want to
make that point because I don't think um
I think sometimes we we make it very
simple and clearcut and I have spent 15
years getting to know how gray it is and
how impactful
and not necessarily in the ways that you
think but in a variety of ways and um
one thing I would like to note is that
when we were talking when we are talking
about a mental health crisis there are a
variety of reasons but one that I don't
think ever really gets talked about is
the fact that we have a generation of
people who have lost uh their authority
figures they have lost their parents
they've lost their uncles their
grandparents my two kids are not
abnormal and people have grown up with
that um reality and during all of this
reality it has been illegal and it has
been criminalized and it's just getting
worse so I I don't I I apologize I'm
very passionate about this I don't want
to dominate the conversation and I
totally get where you're coming from
it's not you know um contentious
whatsoever I I I get that but just to to
kind of clarify where I'm coming from on
this thank you representative
Cel thank you
um so there are a couple things one I
want to Echo um representative Newman's
comment about you know if it's the 10
milligrams is there an amount that makes
it different right is it five milligrams
2 milligrams whatever it is is there
some number that we could get to just on
that part alone that might be more
palatable and more amendable because if
that's the sticking point then that's an
easy solve right um I also want to make
a point it's you know if people have
addiction
um we we've historically called them
addicts but that doesn't serve to help
it just serves to add labels um in my
experience but people suffer from
addiction and we know we can't legislate
our way out of
addiction we know we can't legislate our
way out of mental health even though our
our criminal justice system is the
biggest provider of mental health care
in the state um it doesn't mean that
that's the way we're going to solve it
right by by criminalizing all of these
things to I was listening to a podcast
recently about um an organization that
people can call um when they're using
drugs alone so that there's someone on
the phone who knows their name and their
address and can call 911 if they've
realized they've overdosed right when
the person if the person becomes
non-responsive and the particular story
that that they featured in this
podcast um dealt with an overdose
situation where um you know the per the
call recipient was able to call 911 they
were able to get there in time had it
been 1 minute later it would have been
too late um the EMT managed to
resuscitate the
person they went to the ER the next day
they called the hotline back to use
again and were persuaded not to because
of the risks of uh using the day after
overdosing But ultimately did go through
a cycle right um but they kept being in
communication with the same person they
called the first time and ultimately the
person worked their own way out of their
demons and into rehab and into treatment
and is now answering those calls to help
others and so you know this is a a harm
reduction technique right of of a phone
call doesn't do anything to stop the
person from using it just says if you're
going to use call here so we can
hopefully stop you from dying I was
thinking about representative new's
Comon about like the statistics will go
down about Naran because we don't know I
think it sort of parallels with coid and
coid testing once we had at home tests
the numbers nationally appeared to go
down not because cases went down but
because people didn't have to report it
because you could test at home and
isolate yourself or not as you depending
on your choice about responsibility you
know um I think that what I see in this
is if we can keep someone who is an
addiction issue alive one more
day maybe that's the day they realize
okay it's time for me to get help maybe
it's it's not maybe it's going to take
them 15 more of those days maybe it's
going to take them 40 doses of Naran
before they realize maybe it's going to
take them when they don't even have
enough um space in their neck to inject
into because they've run out of
everywhere else before they realize that
they're you know that they've got
nothing
left but giving someone that one more
day also gives them that one more chance
and and to me that that outweighs
everything there's a a Jewish construct
of you know one who saves a life Saves
the World so if we can save a life by
doing
this we might save the world so that's
that's that's where I'm coming from so
I'm hopeful we can find some number or
some path that would be more palatable
um I don't support people being addicted
you know I want to help them become not
addicted I just want to help them find
the way
forward thank you representative re okay
so no I agree but I would be feel much
better about all of this if we were able
to se separate the um substance misuse
versus the illicit activity what's
catching for me the 10 milligrams I'm
willing to overlook because I agree I
think you know you can take that
minuscule amount or whatever that's
that's just you're not dealing with the
FDA measurements here you're dealing
with Street measurements but um the drug
paraphernalia I just can't if you're
going to bring your drug to get tested
or you have your drug to test that's
fine if you have your fentanyl strips
and you have your drugs you know test it
have at it my problem lies solely in the
definition of paraphernalia because to
me this is enabling a illicit activity
shall not include if we would do away
with this I would feel much better and I
would be willing to keep the nominal
amount may ask a clarification question
so if I if I were to purchase my street
supply of illegal substances illicit
substances and then I want to go get it
tested to make sure it's safer for me to
use I'm just trying to understand
so um I need some way to transport it
with me and so what drug par I'm trying
to understand what with the drug
paraphernalia like what you're saying
would be I'm trying to just trying to
understand where what your language yeah
to test your drug you have your baggie
or whatever it comes in you have your
test strip and you dip it you don't have
to bring it anywhere you can procure
your fentanyl test strips you know as
when you go to those um when wherever
you get your stuff you know you're you
go to those mobile or those mobile
clinic clinics come to you or whatever
or you go they know where to get their
fentanyl test strips so you have five or
seven test strips or how many ever
they're given to you you keep them in
your pocket you get your drug you test
it you don't you know you don't need to
transport it to some place to to have it
done that is my understanding you
procure your test strips you have them
on you um if people are going to those
mobile or those on-site um clinics you
know it's still yeah you if you have
drugs above 10 milligrams you know it's
still an illicit activity you know um so
yeah if you go to those places it's to
get it tested
when you get your shower your food your
clothes but that's not the only way to
do it they you could pick your if you
could get your extra test strips at
those centers to have on you to test in
your using site wherever you're
using um it doesn't mean you're
transporting it all over the conquered
to get tested okay that's my
understanding yeah maybe I'm misreading
because my my understanding is that
essentially we're saying just that we're
excluding from the definition of drug
parapan pelia the testing equipment and
the and and that may be more than just
fenal test strips they may be other
types of testing equipment so maybe I'm
misreading so if you could point to me
where I should be reading I'd appreciate
it um line nine under the drug
paraphernalia they want to do away with
the defin they want to take these words
out of the definition of paraphernalia
they want it to to um paraphernal you
not to include drug but we've already
said okay to fentanyl test strips but
drug checking equipment are processing
preparing packaging repackaging storing
containing you know so they want to take
so I don't even know what would be left
under paraphernalia if you took all of
those words out of the
definition um but the drug I don't know
what other things they use to test drugs
I think there's little kits that like
for cocaine and stuff I we haven't
okayed that we're just you know we're we
passed the Fentanyl and the
sosine um but I just think that this
definition is too broad and um again
it's it's you know it's not a harm
ruction it's just taken it away from the
illicit activity that it is in my
opinion thank you just in my former law
enforcement life uh looking at the
amended portion where it says shall not
include drug checking equipment or
processing I have no problem with that
next line preparing packaging
repackaging storing because again
there's an ore in between all of these
so preparing I could have scales I could
have large amounts of baggies uh
repackaging could be Bales for for
heroin uh storing could be again storing
units for cocaine so that portion there
I do not like the next portion
containing nominal amounts for the
purpose of drug checking I I like the
first two that middle one obviously we
will vote on this and we can strike that
out when we talk to representative Muse
but I like a lot of that but not that
middle portion
you're you're looking at the amendment
now
with it's actually within the bill
itself okay I'm sorry I'm trying to um
yeah so I think this was the one that
representative Muse got as an amendment
and then it got put into the bill it's
on uh page two
line 16 we go down to where it's uh
struck out in lines
1819 so you can speak upon that yes so
you would take
out
I would take out
the where is it here preparing packaging
repackaging storing so that should be
put back into the statute because I see
this as a a bypass an endar around for a
drug trafficker if you will to say I'm
just testing this and it doesn't really
list amounts within that section okay
thank you for
clarifying
represent so now we've got two places
where we agree that the language in the
unapproved
amendment should be changed and there
should be some assertions maybe and some
deletions and some different amounts and
all of
that so I I I would think that probably
the uh appropriate role for this
subcommittee would be to work on what
would be the
whatever the next
unapproved unapproved amendment is and
then when you convene your next meeting
where I probably won't be here you you
can then vote on the two if there happen
to be two opposing amendments you can
vote on the two amendments and you come
out with a result or whatever but I just
think that I think that we've
accomplished a lot by the discussion
we've had here to narrowing down what
the the objections are to an amendment
as it's
written thank
you anyone
else representative C thank you um and
thank you for pronouncing my name
correctly I really appreciate that um so
um so if we look at the single page
Amendment 50 Z 20 20235 15 if we go down
to lines 9 and 10 if that were to say
drug paraphernalia shall not include
drug checking equipment or processing
storing or containing nominal amounts
for the purpose of drug checking but
strikes the words preparing packaging
and
repackaging is is you would be
comfortable with would you be
comfortable with that
language I would I think representative
Reed I don't want to speak for you but
you could interject uh it seems like
we're in agreement with that we're not
really I'm not really caring so much
about that amount because right it's it
is nominal it's that like a
representative no said it's the Lincoln
head it's tiny tiny tiny so may I
propose we uh resubmit this amendment
with our committee names on it with
those changes to present at our next
meeting am I can I do that right
representative
you can do I mean we can do whatever we
want to do and I mean you could even go
and I
I um Brad might have an tell something
about this you could I suppose right now
make an amendment have the amendment
printed up and then you would be able to
vote on that Amendment as the
recommendation to the full committee and
you could do it in this in this meeting
or you could choose to go to another
meeting that's up to the
chair I know we have real and thank you
representative Newman uh I know we have
real busy schedule so if we can try to
bang this out today that would be
excellent uh represent
mu yeah just and you know I don't mean
to drag it out or anything um you know I
but okay so preparing I feel like that's
something that we could get into really
okay what is that entail right um but
when we're saying packaging and
repackaging storing like these kind
these things kind of um are similar in
my mind I mean uh talking about
packaging I mean that's what you carry
it in right like that's that's what it's
contained in so I mean essentially what
that would be is like a bag right so
it's got to be in something um to be
able to get it to a place where you can
test it or whatever and so I feel like
that in that in that you know in this
context makes sense um of course it does
say for the purpose of drug te checking
and then it is you know a nominal amount
so that would really you know it would
have to be a tiny little you know a tiny
little um bit in there there so what
we're talking about is I don't know
itsy-bitsy little bags I just think I
I'm not sure why we would take out
packaging and repackaging because I feel
like the reason those things are in
there is because there're there are
things that it would need to be by
necessity it would need to be
transported in so that you could get it
to a place where you can test it so I
don't like I said I don't mean to
belabor the point but I'm not really
sure why we would necessarily need to
take those out to accomplish what we're
trying to do today thank you represent
question so if somebody buys their drugs
and um I don't know how they would buy
it or or what but I would assume that
they would buy a certain amount they
would scoop off a a minuscule amount put
it in another bag and if they didn't
have their test strips bring it to a
center to test I can understand that use
of packaging and
repackaging but um still I I I I think
that it I would be happy if it said drug
parapan Alia sh not include fentanyl
test strips packaging or or nominal
amounts for drug testing that is just
very narrow very specific and not open
to interpretation you know um because if
you're going to have your drugs in a
bigger bag and you put it in a little
bag you would leave your bigger bag
someplace else I would assume you
wouldn't carry it with you but you might
but then you wouldn't need to repackage
it because that's a lot of manipulation
of a drug that you need to take
I don't know if I did it I would bring
it
all I wouldn't be I wouldn't be doing
that so I'm looking at this as it's
under the fentel test strip and Other
Drug checking equipment we could have
someone who's a dealer a trafficker that
is now going to reference reference this
in their defense they'll have their
fentel little baggies to say look I'm
testing this and that portion there
could exempt them from all of the other
stuff that they're possession within the
drug statute so this is kind of like
we're now circumventing another law
where again the addict and those who are
addicted are truly trying to use this to
help them but then you have the very bad
apples that are going to say oh look at
this a defense attorney is going to look
at this and say my my client can't be
charge because of the statute that's
just me and my law enforcement brain
thinking so would you like to say
something e either
side represent
Newman I want to just look at the words
the exact words in the in the sentence
so it says drug paraphernalia shall not
include drug checking equipment or
processing preparing packaging
repackaging storing or containing a
nominal amounts uh for the purpose of
drug
checking so it seems to me that that
last clause in that paragraph says that
for each one of these things the
packaging and the packaging and
repackaging has to incl has to only is
only allowed when it
is when whatever is defined whatever
those categories are when there is only
a small a nominal amount
associated with that so I don't know
whether that sentence almost stands up
on its own to limit it to any everything
in this bill would have to be related to
a nominal
amount thank you adding on to that where
it's that last portion where it says
preparing packaging repackaging storing
or containing if we can get rid of or
and put shall which contain a nomal
amount so that would then make
everything into that one cozy
sentence yeah because that when I'm
looking at that I'm seeing or so that's
where they're going to circumvent that
if we put shall uh we we'll get the
verbiage for it but shall and that will
link it all into one sentence does this
make sense so take it so we'll keep in
the packaging and preparing whatnot but
take out the or and change the language
to make it specific to the nominal
amount yes that will tie it all in that
way there again a bad apple won't be
able to now use this as a defense this
will truly help those who are addicted
to get their testing and that's how I
view it yes okay that I would be
comfortable with that um because it yes
I think that that makes sense and
yeah
yes okay so we will be in recess for for
a couple
minutes
I will now reopen the subcommittee work
session on House Bill
470 representative
selig so um if if changing the word or
to a more appropriate word is sufficient
we would be delighted to see the new
word or how that works because I don't
know the legal ins and outs um since I'm
not a lawyer and I don't play one on TV
um but we would be delighted when we
reconvene to have that Amendment or to
see drafts of it in advance of that that
we can fully support however the process
works because again I'm as new as
you thank you represent Reed okay I
would like to go word by word and see
which ones we could agree on again I go
back to this being too broad um more
moving away from harm reduction to um
not addressing the ilicit elicit ity
part of it so if we can go word by word
um and see which one we can agree on um
I think that would be a good start so um
drug equipment um as being
in Excuse me yes on on on the amendment
on um
0515 lines 910 okay all right so drug
paraphernalia shall not include and this
is where the sticking points are because
I feel it's too broad of a defin uh too
broad drug checking equipment if it
doesn't say if it's limited to fentanyl
test strips I would be okay with that
how are your what are your feelings on
that you want it go ahead we can have
this as an open discussion okay thank
you I I think we need it to be more than
just fenal test strips because there's
an other things that get put into drugs
that are also
dangerous and so to me having more
having it leaving it as drug checking
equipment is and and I would defer to
representative new who's got far more
knowledge but do we have other tools to
test I mean I know we have something for
cocaine but what other what other
equipment do is commonly
used represent so as of now what we
passed out of this committee um and on
the Full House and was um also passed
through Committee in in the Senate full
Senate and signed off on by the governor
um what that is what ended up being we
we passed the testing and analyzing
equipment removing testing and analyzing
equipment I was happy with that the
Senate amended it a little bit and made
it so that it only exempts um feny and
xylazine test strips and we were
fortunate that xylazine test strips had
come out right before we had the hearing
so um luckily you know our uh Lauren
from uh New Hampshire har reduction
Coalition was there with a test strip
and and saying we just have this the
thing is um so I so just to actually let
me just answer the question in the first
place so there are things like um
testing the um test strips what what the
test strips do is very simply say
whether or not this substance is in it
even in that context it's not one thing
that tests for Fentanyl and xylazine
even it's one for feny one for xylazine
it tells you whether or not it's there
yes or no green or red right um so what
the analyzing equipment is and there are
a variety of things I was trying to find
it in here cuz like I said I I printed
up all these um I went on a little
research bench um but uh I can send it
to the to the committee subcommittee
afterwards but ah there was a really
good discussion of what I think it's
actually in this one okay so uh rapid
response fenel uh testing strips uh btnx
Laboratories uh Canada anyway that
that's not the point but it's right in
here what it was actually is not
something that was sent out this study
itself was not this research itself
paper was not sent out individually this
was in a uh in the list of references of
another letter that we got and so so
people may not have looked at this so
let me just share uh the information
there's a um trar well that I guess
that's the the uh brand name of it but
uh Ramen uh spectrometer thermofisher
scientific okay um and then there's a
Brooker Alpha foror transform inferred
Booker Optics what this is is this is
kind of breaking down things so number
one there is equipment that would need
to be stationary it's very expensive it
would need to be stationary this is like
a mass spectrometer that you see on the
on the doctor shows and stuff like that
that would need to be in a specific
location where people would need to get
to that location uh perhaps there could
be mobile but it would this would be uh
something that is you know uh that is
brought to people or people go there um
and and this is why they would need to
bring this uh why these other things
would need to be legalized so that they
can actually transport it there or
um if there is uh you know a Grassroots
organization that goes out on the street
you know goes out and finds folks and
goes to a place where people are meets
up has a specific day something like
that they can take a sample of these
things bring it to their location where
they have one of these you know big
machines big heavy expensive machines
and be able to test it there that would
break down exactly what's in something
how much of something there is in there
it is the the top-notch gold standard of
being able to analyze exactly what is in
this uh very small Supply supply of
drugs then there is kind of an in
between one so there's the yes or no
very simple yes or no that we've already
legalized for some substances there's
the breaks everything down and then
there's a middle one um that people
would be able to um organizations would
be able to um bring to locations and be
able to analyze something it would tell
you how much or I'm sorry it would tell
you what is in it not necessarily how
much as I understand it not necessarily
break it down there's this percent and
this percent and this percent but it
would be able to tell you that there is
this this this these you know specific
things that we are testing for but more
than one and that would be um I mean it
it's just invaluable to have this
information to know where things are um
to know when things crop up and that
kind of stuff so um I hope that's a a
decent explanation I can also send you
the information about these different
kind types that's excellent because
we're dealing with two different um
populations here we're dealing with
organizations that are testing to see
what's on the street as from and and
that's different than the than the users
that are on the street so we're talking
about testing equipment for this is more
more this is a broader um bill that's
going to Encompass the organization and
the street level so it's going to so
okay that that I can understand yeah we
we people that are running these mobile
clinics should be able to have these
spectrometers and all those other
testing equipment but isn't that covered
under Licensing in in when they get
their you know when they get their their
CER certific certifications and
Licensing to run these mobile units
isn't that under that their
umbrella is this like
redundant as I understand it there are
very specific organizations that are um
exempt from you know that are able to
provide these things and able to provide
these Services um it's not a lot so no
it is not it's it's not necessarily
redundant I do think that um this was
made in This was um designed in a way
that it does does allow for individuals
to be able to go to a place
so yes uh it's very important that we uh
protect people who are working in this
area um to be able to to do that like
what what you're saying like New
Hampshire har reduction Coalition but
also um you know they also um other
organizations that are working with um
people who are struggling with this
anyway but it's also important that
people to my mind um
that people are able to go to a place if
there is a central location where um
individuals who want to test their you
know their supply can go to essential so
that wouldn't necessarily be somebody
who's covered under their um lure or you
know uh an organization or something
like that so first of all there's very
specific organizations um and as far as
I know no I mean nowhere near enough but
a very very um small amount of people
and we have a huge problem I just want
to bring this up really really quickly
and R I know you want to want to speak I
think I've I've I've covered what I
meant to but um but I I just want to
talk about the idea that we have a huge
problem in the North country and we
don't have really a wonderful in
infrastructure out there this it's
people are it's it's more sparse it's
harder for people to access these things
it's harder for people to get to places
where they and there just aren't the
support you know there we've come a long
way baby but there aren't um there is
nowhere near what we need and and it's
kind of understandable why but things
like this allow for um much more rural
areas that don't necessarily have um
don't necessarily have um the
infrastructure to be able to support
people um in an Institutional way with
these people who we allow to do it I
think we also need to provide for for um
you know for folks up in the North
Country to be able to access these
things as well and I think yeah yeah I
think we need a division a clarification
between um organizations um that provide
these Services versus um the people that
um are for lack for um your local
everyday user you know what I'm saying
there needs to be a line that says you
can have the spectrometer you could have
all the equipment you need to run your
organization and I understand the North
Country sparse but the people up in the
North Country certainly should have
access to their T Fentanyl and xylazine
test strips but not the spectrometers
and the heavy Duty stuff which would
again feed into the trafficking
component part of it which they probably
wouldn't have I don't know thank you uh
representative Newman yeah I I agree
with what representative Reed said I'm
I'm trying to figure out so you have the
three types of equipment that you said
but it sounds like that the middle and
the highend stuff is in an
organization and we can we you say we
have passed a law that that does the
other drugs other than fentanyl so I'm
just wondering would the in the North
Country would not would a user be have a
spectrometer or any of that kind of
stuff or would they be using the strips
and if we cover if we cover them having
the test strips that do that would that
be sufficient where we could take this
out and put some language in like
that I just want to respond yeah I just
wanted to respond to that so um yes I
think that it is very helpful and good
in the North Country to have feny and
xylazine test stps be I think we can all
agree on that I hope we do because we
just passed it but um but yes you're
you're absolutely right I mean a
spectrometer is not something that a
user would have a spectrometer I would
argue is probably not even something
that a that a drug dealer um would have
right or um but as far as mobile units
are concerned in being able to go out
and test something in you know somewhere
where there is a central location and
things like that those are um that I
think is a is a very important um
element of being able to address things
like that in the North country because
there isn't the physical infrastructure
of locations right so mobile units are
are um very important in that way do do
they do that now do they go out mobile
and people bring stuff or I mean what's
the situation that you're concerned
about I do not believe for um for this
type of
equipment I mean do they I mean is that
does that happen now that people bring
drugs to be tested at these that doesn't
exist it is illegal I mean
okay I'll just interject and then
representative seling maybe they can get
some sort of exemption like the
Standalone buildings do for the mobile
units uh I just think we can't just open
this up uh because again as we were
saying here it's just going to we do
want them to get the help but until we
can get those mobile units up and
running then maybe we can get their
exemption but in in the meantime I'm
seeing this as the traffickers the
dealers are just going to circumvent it
representative selling so I just want to
point out that we we've been focusing on
fenel strips which is great obviously we
need to you know help people not
accidentally have fentanyl or car
fentanyl or any of the number of drugs
but those aren't the only things I think
we need to be testing for I think you
know there's other things if um you know
thinking back a couple of decades um
thinking about all of the different
things that can be that marijuana for
example can be laced with which might
include LSD it might include
methamphetamines it might include other
things and so I think if we limit this
to fenel and I forget the other one
xylazine test strips we are making it so
that um especially if we ever manag to
get marijuana legalized in New Hampshire
but people who might be right now
procuring supplies of things like
that um by by taking out any by by
limiting it to fenel and and the other
test strip we're making it so that if
someone wanted to have some sort of
equipment if that was available to test
for other substances isn't available and
so you know I'd want them to have the
ability to get things tested for LSD for
um you know any for other substances
besides just those two and I worry about
making the focus too narrow Again by by
keeping it at the nominal amounts we're
we're taking away the drug dealers right
um access but also having done a quick
Google search these spectrometer things
are between 50 and
$70,000 each so you know your average
drug dealer is not really likely to be
uh procuring those
so represent
Newman so I think we have to figure out
a way to get the wording to be that
specifically for this bill when we use
the word when we might even put a
definition of drug checking equipment in
there and put in there that for the
purposes of this bill drug checking
equipment is for nominal amounts only so
so that you always connect what you're
exempting in here to just nominal
amounts anytime you
have drug checking equipment for amounts
not other than that it's it's it doesn't
apply generally to where they could get
around but that you have to go to the
lawyers to do that to figure out exactly
how you connect the two not nominal and
Drug checking equipment and only for
this bill so I don't know what you think
about that or if that can be done we'd
have to further Define nominal if we're
still going with the 10 milligrams
because a nominal to me to you is it's
arbitrary I understand repres
representative selling so but if if it's
that specific would it make it so that
these like mobile units that are going
to say a homeless encampment who might
have a larger testing
capacity would would that eliminate
their ability to function I just want to
make sure we're
not I don't know if that's a separate
category I'm sorry I'm viewing this as
the end user and not the testing centers
so I know it's an larm Force I can't
speak for all of them I'm not going to
go shake down a mobile testing unit and
say oh look at what you got I'm going to
arrest all of you that's not how I'm
viewing it again I can't speak for all
in law enforcement but I think we're
looking at the user in this particular
Bill and yes I do want those mobile
units to happen especially for the
people in the North Country what are
they going to travel 4 hours to test
their drugs
that's I don't know I agree with
representative I agree with represent
representative tenar and Newman I think
that we could specify in the bill this
is for the end user and um organizations
however we could word it is it our
exempt because I police are not going to
arrest mobile units they're not going to
do that
so but to for clarification I would hope
not I just I would hate for us to
accidentally I I know there was another
LSR I submitted for research and I they
brought forward to me a number of things
that I had not even known existed that
my LSR would have caused some serious
unintended
consequences and so um I just want to
make sure that we're not accidentally
making things like mobile testing units
um for harm reduction illegal by Framing
this too narrowly I just I want to make
sure we're protecting those
abilities thank you
represent mobile testing units are thank
you um mobile testing units are only as
valuable as the information that they
can gather and that depends on people
being able to bring to safely feel safe
in bringing what they have to a mobile
unit even in the first place so I mean
it we we would be limiting the ability
of our of those mobile units of these
organizations that we depend on to uh to
help us understand what is on the
streets we would be limiting their
ability in that people need to be able
to to bring things there without feeling
like they're going to get arrested I
mean think about this scenario and I'm
I'm not saying like you know there's
boogey men out there doing this kind of
thing but think about a mobile unit that
sets up on a certain day every week or
something like that right this we have
that now people will go and they'll
they'll set up on a certain week they
give out you know Narin a variety of
different things syringe exchanges um
all all kinds of different things so
they they literally have a schedule
where they say all right we're going to
be here on this week now if somebody
feels like they can't uh be comfortable
in bringing something there or accessing
those uh things where if you know not to
create a boogeyman but if if if that is
known then it is also known to law
enforcement well it's fish in a barrel
then people who are coming there that
creates a situation where whether or not
that is real to someone in that
situation that is the uh that is the
perception or could be the perception it
just it limited it limits the amount of
information we are able to get because
it maintains a level of distrust and
discomfort and a lack of safety in being
able to access those things as well so
it it people need to be uh people need
to feel Comfort I'm repeating myself now
I'm sorry but I I just want to make sure
that what I'm saying is clear it's
creating a situation where it's great
that people are to be able to do this
but people also need to be uh need to
feel that they can go there um without
the threat of uh
prosecution um and they need to feel
comfortable go there as well or else
we're not we're not getting the full
benefit of of what we're trying to do
here thank you I'm viewing this bill in
my law enforcement eyes and I I know
that was great that you brought up the
fish in the barrel uh I do not see law
enforcement hiding out in the bushes
wanting seeing people testing then they
go out and then they pull them over this
is me pulling a guy over some guy is
beating up on his wife or something I
happen to find this this is not the fish
in the barrel when I was a trooper there
was a methodone clinic in Hudson and I
don't know if it's even there anymore I
100% tell you that Hudson was not
hanging out there just waiting to try to
see if these people have methodone on
them heroin I wasn't doing that either
and I know your concerns that that could
happen there could be law enforcement
out there that need a a a pinch and
they're going to hang out and do that I
view that as almost entament to a degree
uh and I know you're chomping at the bit
you can reply I just want to clarify
that I'm not saying that that could
happen I'm saying that that could be the
perception from people who have already
had negative interactions with police or
I mean it's criminalized so I I'm I'm
making no judgments and I certainly
don't expect that to be the case but I
am trying to look through the
perspective of the people who we want to
be in to be uh to feel safe in in
accessing this you know what I mean so I
don't I don't think that either you know
but I I'm I'm just trying to make sure
that the point is to reduce barriers um
so that we can get the best information
we can know exactly what we're dealing
with um and in order to do that in the
context of a um of you know an illicit
substance the way to do that is to limit
the amount the nominal amount we've
defined the nominal amount we have uh
we're talking about changing the
language so that we're making sure that
all of this all of the language that we
have is directly related to that nominal
amount I think that's a you know I think
that's a wonderful thing I I think
that's really what the goal would be
here
right thank you and represent Reed did
you have further no
represent I just have a comment for the
[Laughter]
chair and I think it is we are at a
point in the the decision that you have
that you have to make is is whether you
want to Wordsmith this right now whether
you want to get with the lawyers to
Wordsmith something to do in another
meeting or whatever it is we're really
talking about what we want to do with
just the words in this amendment to see
I mean I don't think this amendment is
going to go the way it's not going to be
approved it's we are not going to make a
recommendation the way it is now so you
might either want to look at that you
might want to do that today or you might
want to have figure out what you want to
do based upon what we've discussed today
and and get the wording so that in a
future meeting of the subcommittee or
the regular committee you can make a
determination what you want to
do thank you again for your Sage advice
I definitely will wrap this up I think
with just us five here we might be kind
of just going around in circles let's
get more players involved in this to get
other perspectives because but I think
we work really well together to really
craft this to hopefully get this ought
to pass so uh we'll have to reconvene at
some point for uh another subcommittee
meeting and I know that's really tough
with everything happening and uh for
jobs but we're uh we're going to be uh
adjourning this meeting for a future
subcommittee and hopefully we can try to
work on the dates today that work with
the main subcommittee uh so I will be
adjourning this meeting of House Bill